Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier!
and welcome to Ira.
Now, this is Ira act 1
of, what I only assume to be an
episodic type game.
that's about...
something I don't know!
Once again I'm going into this blind.
"The current Ira demo contains Pre-Alpha gameplay."
All I know
It's another highly rated indie game and I'm always happy to play these types of games.
But this one seems more of a...
story-driven type game.
"The smell of rocket fuel hangs in the air"
"even this far outside of town."
"The year is 1932 and summer fades over the lands
"surrounding Pilgrimage as launch day fast approaches."
What were they launching in 1932?
*Train horn sounds*
"Anticipation fills the air and the world's gaze is drawn to the tiny town"
"as the final trains make their way into the station."
Announcer: Good Evening, You're listening to Pilgrimage News Radio
Announcer: Where the words are as true as they are fresh! I'm Cutty  Copper and I'll be your host tonight.
Announcer: The Town is a-buzz for once, with the Holocene only weeks away!
Announcer: And the Pilgrimage once again thrusted into the world's spotlight.
Announcer: Earth's first interstellar vessal will depart from the Pilgrimage launch center.
Announcer: Traversing the void of interstellar space, in order to explore the new mysteries of the Lithic Systm
Announcer: Don't forget to pick up your immune tickets for the launch
Announcer: ??????- if you have the pocketbook
Announcer: In other news, the Martian mining season is once again upon us and many listeners have noticed the influx of seasonal workers in town.
Announcer: Keep in mind that the world is watching; and so please let's all be on our best behavior.
Announcer: And save the ?????? and rabble rousing for the mines
Announcer: We don't need any incidents with the press.
-Announcer's voice fades away-
Okay that's bizarre, why are they so worried about the press?
Also! Why are people on Mars? Also! Why is it 1932 and we're interstellar space here?
And also, why is Pilgrimage (which is supposedly a small town).....
That they've been se- talking about the center for all this?
Hello~
OH! Ohhh I get choices!!
Ummmm....
Let's see..."Why? What's the next town?"
"What's wrong with Pilgrimage?"
What the hell?
Damn... OH! Oh god-
Ah that's crazy!!
Man they did so much world building! And I know it was exposition but even so
I am like fascinated by what's going on here
And I don't even know what's going on here!!
Why does InteleCo own a town and what's the importance of Pilgrimage to the... -ability to go to the stars?!?
Like, Why this small town?!
Doesn't make much sense to me but then again what do I know?
Oh, is that me?
Am I Ira?!
Am I this Ira fella?
"Is there anything I can do to help?" Because I don't even remember mom even talking to me
Also why? Why is the technology of everything else like to the period but.... Man!
"Before I leave I mean"
Let's see...
"Aren't you excited to go to Mars again?"
Ok, I got it dad!
I'm gettin' it
I'm helping
I almost grabbed it. Oh I got it, ok...
Man, that's weird
Hello! What's with my eyes too?!
Looks like I just have two buttons for eyes.
ugh
-clinking noises-
You got it dad!
Imma go get that, good bye!!
-Markiplier monkey sound effects-
This better be the way to the barn!
I think I may have -screwed- up
-More Markiplier money sound effects-
ehhh gotta go to the barn
Any minute now! Gonna get there, SOME DAY!
annnyyy minute now... wish there would have been directions on which way to go.
But yeah! This is just so fascinating like I have so many questions...
And also it's beautifully made, I mean the animation is janky but this is obviously just a demo
For what they got here, the side scrolling elements of it -it reminds me of you know
ahhh- Inside! Which I just played but that's just because of the side scrolling elements of it are probably similar
"Call up there"?!
HELLRRR?!
-Cue Mark's freaked out face- (so cute)
-Climb to the loft-
-Another Markimoo face-
"Search the loft"
This seems like a bad idea but I'm gonna do it anyway
"Feel around-" Yeah! Feel around there!
Feel the monster's teeth
I'm just caressing the metal breasts of a cyborg! That's what I'm doing...
Okay then!
I guess I'm just gonna look for uhhh fuel line
-Radio music loudly echos-
Okay, that's creepy
-Radio music suddenly cuts off-
Yea, no joke!
eugh! If I felt a smooth metal breast in the darkness and then-
-heard the haunting sounds of that goddamn radio, I'd be a little concerned too! So...
We're just not going to talk about that
We're not gonna- I'm curious to go back though. I am curious,
Let's see if there's anything new
Ohhhhh... Sureee, you're a little bitch baby!
Is that what I'm getting here? You're a little cowardly bitch baby??
Can't gather up the courage to go in the darkness and feel up some metal boobs huh?!
Ohh little baby, it'll be okay. Someday you'll be brave
Alright dad, I got- I got a rubber hose and I made it to first base with a toaster!!
It was awesome!
Anyway here you go
-subtle county guitar plays in the background-
-it's a sad guitar sound-
ugh, that's sad...
This isn't a good-- This isn't very assuring DAD!
Let's see...
"Are you  upsset because mom is getting sicker?"
Oh man, we're going into the dark levels of exposition now!
dot dot dot
Aww  "I'm sorry!"
Oh that's so SAD!!
Oh it's so sad!
God...Man, this is horrifying.
To buy your own equipment... You can barely trust th- the government's equipment that they give me!
My god! I wouldn't buy my own!
No, actually wait, th- that's backwards.
I would definitely buy my own! But if I didn't have the money for it I'd be screwed..
Let me just wander into mom and dad's room
Squeeeek
Hello?
"Ira?"
"Oh, I didn't know you were asleep"
"Is everything okay?"
"Okay, I'll pu- put on dinner"
That'll be lovely
Man, that's so sad
ohhh, so sad...
Why is she sick?
Why does dad have to leave?!
Why is world the way that world is?!
Now I gotta admit that, you know, graphically it's not terribly interesting right now
But, like the story and like the environment. You know the world that they're building already, is just really fascinating
Like legitimately, it's- it's honestly fascinating because everywhere I look
technology is exactly as it was back in the day
Maybe a little bit ahead
But, even so for a space faring civilization that has worker's union on Mars
-Pot begins to boil-
That's- that's a little interesting
Medical- Oh no...
Oh, that's so sad
I mean if I had to guess, it's probably cancer
But even so -shudder-
"Go to Ira's room"
Well I should probably go get dad but I want to make sure that everything here is okay
"Join Now"
Is there anything here to even look at?
"Go to hall" Nah, there's nothing
Well, he's into Holocene and-
-The Martian Union! That's. That's the interest that every growing lad should have in the-
-the heartland of what I can assume is maybe America?
Oh
Well that's disconcerning
That's...
Imma- Wait! Woah where's? What. Heyyy
Mom's just gone?!
What the hell's going on here!?
Ohhhhh kayy??
OHHHH
OHH!!
what??
-confused Markimoo Face-
-Markimoo is still confused and now concerned-
oh theres a grave
oh no!
ohhhh nooo
oh what is happening?
does it?!?!
I don't know if it does!
like what was with the cyborg whatever in the
barn?
wa was that about?
what is all of this?
ohhh god it's empty
guiding Ira through a tomb of
something
i didn't finish that
oh god
ohhhh that's scary
buuuut lemme go check here first
I know you're eager beaver to go in there but I wanna see
if my room's available
it is
I bet this is depressing
oh good
What the hell is on the walls?!?
What's with the symbols?
What is that?
AAAAlienssss???
maybe
i don't know
Why is the refrigerator gone?
Why'd they put a cloth on the grandfather?
Okay...
does it?
I don't- okay
oh god
oh that's obsession
I know about obsession
that looks like a LOT of obsession
ehhh
okay
lithics buths?
what is that?
what?
I've been nowhere, Only by looking backwards, here is everywhere
well there's no point in looking backwards...
and here is everywhere sounds like
some profound bullshit so
I'll say that
Nothing is certain, no way is set; There is only one path;  I can only go where I have been before
nope! bottom's not true
there's never one path
so nothing is certainnnn
Hey! how 'bout Screw You
Naw
no- I- no I don't know
I have no idea
Wake up
IIIII'm not asleep
It's not ALL a dream
I fell asleep in that
booooooo-kay
We've reached a new leval weird-a
It's the symbols that were in my room that's for sure
Well that doesn't look good. Is it a time machine?
Ohhhhh kee doke then
eughhh
uhhhhh
oh *mark realizes*
It was like a freezing tube
and  he musta went on that trip to the other stars
really?
oohh kay!
ohhh that's why it was all a dream
okay so to catch you all up
in case you guys got lost
because it could be easy
He went- on that trip
TOOOO SPACE
To see all the other stars
And explore the " lithics system" which
I don't know what that is...
but they're exploring the lithics system
and he went on that beause he must have lost his mother
and then I bet his dad died on Mars
so he found no other purpose than to
go to the stars
So is everyone else dead or are they still frozen?
That seems baaaaad
Where am I what's happening
hello?
How can I get out of here?
I feel like I been hit by a truck
what incident?
So the holocene 1 was the first ship in his chilhood
This is the holocene 2 the second mission
But they're filled with dead bodies
okay i was completely right they're filled with- dead bodies
*sounds of disgust*
hahaha
that was my humor programming because I'm pretty sure I'm a robot
ah good- good to see hydroponics is doing well
GOOD! i think...
is this where all the rats came from?
I don't know why there are rats on the holocene but oh well
*cough*
Are you saying that everyone on this ship is dead?
oh wait
*sad voice* yes...
hahahaha...
okay...
lonlieness is excatly what you've always wanted: right?
the crushing isolation of life in space
with a robot companion
who cpuld ask for more?
Why are you showing this to me
of which i have none, because I am a robot
Do you even know what you're saying?
Moving Along!!
Ahh yes
It's me!
Hello!
I am your captain
a robot
Probably because they're all dead
I already asked that question
What are you?
you're just a computer?
okey dokey then
Let's just have a conversation
I gotta admit this is amazingly awesome
and interesting
The limitations of what you see are actually
being, like, contermanded by the story
which i'm totally on board with
uhhh dead
Why do I know this sound?
and blow out you eardrums
ooooooooo or blow up the entire ship
okay goodbye I'm gonna run!
oh boy
did we make it?
We might'a made it!
We mighta made it
That doesn't look like a pla- ohhh kay here we go then
is this the beginning of subnautica?
Well... that's a HAPPINESS alarm
i'm gonna do that by FIRING the rockets
Is that laughing or coughing?
Could be Freddy laughing in the distance!
No?
Alrighty then. What have you got for me?
Bring it on! Im' ready to face any challenge
ohh it's a radio tower!
coool, cool
ahhhh nooo!
noooo!
aw you can't end it there!
nooooooooooo
nooooooo
Aw no I was so into it!
I was so into it!
Awww god it was hitting all my buttons
THe space button, The mystery button, The slightly scary button
The IRA button
aww no
oh it's on kickstarter
man, i gotta support this one
You guys don't have to but I, I gotta support this one
That was super, mmmmmm duper cool
That was super duper cool
I love that a lot
like...
I mentioined while I was playing it the limitations of the graphics and the animation,
But just the fact that the story
was soooo captivating
even though it was filled with exposition, yes
but you gott establish it somehow and this is the easiest way to do it
so, still
uh yes
sassy robot captain
ohhhhh lost child whose parents are dead
oh mystery of the lithic system I WANNA KNOW
I wanna know it all, that was really cool
so either way,
that is Ira,
Act 1
If this game gets kickstarted and gets released in full,
I wanna see so much of it
I think it would benefit with a little more polish on the graphical side of things,
it had a bit of a limbo vibe, an inside vide
I think it could work with being developed in that way
but not in the same, like, game obviously
but just in that style of side scroller and the flexibility of movement and all that
so, this could be really cool
thank you everybody so much for watching
lemme know what you thought of this down in the comments below
And as always I will see you, In the next video. Bye Bye!